oh yeah I think it's our generation is
different obviously you know like where
we're changing [ __ ] up yeah I mean it's
in the biggest way yeah because you guys
are hitting the culture but when I
started there was nobody yeah we had
Margaret and then the generation before
her was people like Tamiya Otsuki Johnny
you know I mean do two people with the
thick accent and so now is why there was
like their novelty like yeah I mean I
don't told this before but there was a
Korean guy named Johnny Yoon at The
Comedy Store in the early 80s his
opening line got an applause break and
this was it he comes on stage
thick accent he's got a tuxedo on hmm he
goes in front of a packed room he stares
up the audience and he goes like this
two-minute applause break he didn't have
to write a joke he just has to say hat
all put him and it's got a two-minute
applause break there's no setup
punchline point of view nothing there's
like one like a Midwestern couple they
give a standing ovation like they gave
him two movies they called me please
they call me Bruce yeah
and they call me Bruce two from now one
word yeah and then he became the Johnny
Carson of Korea he went back with that
[ __ ] made it America that's day yeah
imagine if you had a if he didn't have
an Asian accent I think about I can make
a killing yo like maybe not here but if
I go to Australia or some [ __ ] if with
an Asian accent yeah like a fake
Malaysian accent and on stage
you mean like I doing a live show or
something like just pretending that why
do you uh because I guess they I think I
do it here still any more trouble
well it's a different market I guess
yeah
[Music]